i'm watching perry mason and loving it
it's fantastic
i mean the cast is absolutely incredible
and
it it looks amazing i mean the art
direction i'm terry mason i
i feel like i'm in 1931 los angeles it's
extraordinary
and i love your character eb
eb is this sort of mentor counterpart
to perry mason i feel like you're his
he looks up to you you're his uh someone
who's kind of a mentor figure to him
but your your character is interesting
to me because i feel like he's
struggling with aging out is that right
that's exactly right
and in in the course of it uh perry
mason sort of sees
his feet of clay uh it's a fascinating
character i mean
look conan i'm 74 years old i'm
approaching the time in my life when
every day i will worry about losing my
viability
turns out those are all the roles that
are coming my way
it's a wonderful thing to play because
it's
it's it's it's it's got a wonderful
humor to it
it's got a sadness to it and it it
serves the story wonderfully because it
the beginning of this series is an
origin story how did
mason become an attorney well he becomes
an attorney by doing
a better job than his mentor right so
and i also i love the relationship
between your character e.b
and uh his assistant della street it
reminds me a lot of my relationship with
my assistant sona
woman that poor woman
[Laughter]
juliet rylance plays the part fantastic
actress from england and boy did she get
it right
well we have a clip here uh from uh
perry mason
and i think we're going to cut to that
now we're just basically seeing your
character here uh
in action his uh this is uh this is him
i think
we get a sense of his character here
from this clip great let's have a look
i came to this little pueblo about a
year before he ascended
to the supreme court since that time
justice holmes has distinguished himself
as the nation's foremost jurist
and los angeles has disgraced itself
as a gomorrah where truth is bought and
sold
like the head of a rutabaga
what are you waving about he just wants
me out of the picture chief
this is why i have taken up the cause of
emily dodson
when a state aims its annihilating power
against a mere
individual who will stand up against it
who will defend the defenseless who will
fight for justice
against a heartless expediency
this is what your readers
need to know yes of course uh
something else our readers would like to
know where do you go to eat
when you have a night out
i am fond of the french dip at
philippe's
all right that's not weird we don't get
to actually see it
pretty good pretty good uh well
let's make sure i get the uh the word
out uh
thank you so much for doing this perry
mason airs sundays at nine on hbo and
it's available to stream on hbo max and
trumpy dumpty wanted a crown
versus for a despotic age is available
september 29th and uh it's a delight
it's so good that someone stole our copy
i praise indeed for a book these days
you